a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
or maybe just outside London some lucky
fans recently got up close and personal
with the Millennium Falcon after
sneaking on set of Star Wars Episode 8
i'm simon and this is your intergalactic
news update filming continues on Star
Wars Episode 8 and secrecy around the
production remains as tight as you would
expect nevertheless occasional onset
images have emerged and the latest batch
revealed the Millennium Falcon has taken
by some enterprising fans who snuck onto
the set outside London these images also
feature a reconstruction of the Jedi
steps on the planet of apt ohm which
featured at the end of the force awakens
for that film they were shot on the
Irish island of Skellig in a recent
interview for Rolling Stone Oscar Isaac
who plays Poe Dameron in the new Star
Wars films was the latest to suggest
that directory and Johnson would be
taking the series in some interesting
new directions in the new film there's a
lot more to do what happens now is the
heroes get tested all three of them get
tested immensely John boyega who plays
Finn also emphasized the film's change
of tone during an interview with variety
at the Cannes Film Festival it's a
different take darker bigger someone
will say how do you get bigger than
force awakens but it's crazy episode 8
opens in December 2017 you won't have to
wait that long to see a new Star Wars
movie as rogue one comes out later this
year are you excited for the next
installment of Star Wars let me know in
the comments or come find me on Twitter
i'm at the Jagan or thanks for watching
and for all your entertainment news keep
it gamespot